everybody raise your glasses to the
senator
Ted Kennedy in the White House in 72
[Music]
my family there's no more important word
we share a lifetime bomb
[Music]
we have a situation here on
Chappaquiddick it has been an accident
we can't find Mary Jo
[Music]
what the hell happened last night I was
driving do you have any idea the court
of public opinion will have your head on
a stake we tell the truth or at least
our version of it all you know that
every effort possible was made to save
her what do we do to have the senator a
dead body holds a lot of Secrets
supposed to be the difference between
guilt and innocence are you saying that
there's a possibility that maybe she
didn't drown I could I had her out of
that kind 25 minutes if I got the call
[Music]
but no one called
[Music]
sometimes path your long there's not
always a path to choose not stopping you
from making that choice yourself
[Music]
I can't what'd you do this said you
watch o self-destruct
oh my god what have I done
[Music]
you